foreign
Lauderdale hi Tina how are you
hi guys I appreciate your
some my my question is around using a
HELOC to put 20 down on a new home nope
and then selling the current home right
after closing on the new home
oh that home
I got confused okay yeah so you're going
to close on you're going to close on
another property before yours closes
I I would like to so that's pretty
dangerous I just yeah okay what happens
if it doesn't close you got two house
payments and you know what you become
after that we call them a motivated
seller who sells their house cheap
because they get stuck
three times that happened to me whoa
you didn't learn after the first one no
no three times I have gone to closing or
within a week of closing the deal has
fallen through oh when I'm trying to
sell a property oh yeah yeah I see okay
and yeah we're going to close on the
second one after the first one closes
I just did that I just did that I am in
my second real estate property now
um and when I sold the first home and to
get into this new home that I live in
now
um it was really stressful for me to not
have anywhere to live like in the
interim I happen to just you know what's
more stressful two house payments
how long of a gap are you talking here
um I mean I would immediately like when
I would close
the original home up for sale I guess my
idea of doing it that way is because you
know I um this closing on this new this
is
the sale that I did just now it was
really stressful for me the move I was I
need to find a home where am I gonna
live
um you know and I would have preferred
to be able to secure a home for me first
so write a contract on the other on the
property you're purchasing contingent on
the sale of yours and set the closings
up on the same day
but if yours doesn't if your current
house doesn't close you don't close on
the new one
because you're going to end up with two
house payments in a market that has
slowed down with higher interest rates
and uh you're gonna be calling me two
years from now going I've done the
dumbest thing I got two house payments
that's killing me
can you help me Dave
okay and then
aside from that so what if I could take
out a HELOC enough to pay for a home
cash
um because I have quite a bit of well
enough equity
um in my current home listen here's what
Tina you just you be you okay you go be
you that's what you need don't take out
a HELOC ever ever period ever sell your
stinking house and move and quit talking
to me about stress you're trading one
kind of stress for another because you
don't perceive the risk that after 30
years of doing what I do I've seen
people step in it up to their knees and
I'm begging you not to do that I'm
begging you